You probably already know
about Android Studio's
live templates,
abbreviations displayed
as code completion options
that insert a templated snippet
into your code.
There are dozens
of live templates
available in Android Studio.
But did you know you can
create your own dynamic live
templates?
If your least favorite
piece of boilerplate code
hasn't yet been
templatized, it's
easy to create your
own live template.
Here, we're saving
a shared preference.
It's a common pattern where
typically only the key name
and value vary.
It's also not uncommon
to forget to call apply.
Let's copy this code and
go to the Preferences menu.
Navigate to Editor,
then Live Templates.
Then select Android, and choose
to Add a New Live Template.
Enter an abbreviation
that will be
used as a shortcut and
a helpful description.
Then we paste in our code,
fully qualify the classpaths,
and replace the paths
with our code snippet
that will be different
each time with variables.
We'll be able to tab through
these when entering values.
This template is applicable
within the context of a Java
statement.
When we type a
resource string name,
we want it to offer us
order completion options.
With our live
template defined, we
can start typing
the abbreviations.
Select it from the
auto completion hint
by pressing Tab, and then
paste it in our snippet.
Enter each value, tabbing
between them, and you're done.
More code with fewer keystrokes
thanks to Android Studio
live templates.
[MUSIC PLAYING]